Russell Wilson opened up to Michele this  morning about his fairytale wedding to  Sierra  last weekend in England I really liked  that she shared from behind the scenes  of the big day was of you and her son it  was just very heartwarming do you want  more kids are you gonna expand the  family I'll take one at a time you know  just we're grateful just take we're just  grateful opportunity and ultimately you  know it's just about you know spend  quality time with each other and Russell  is already getting back to work Sunday  night he hosts Nickelodeon Kids Choice  sports 2016 she's excited to be here you  know for this week and it's gonna be an  awesome week and we're excited to just  have a lot of fun with the kids you know  here the Kids Choice sports and it's  gonna be a great time